Let's go to the phones at six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty, starting today
with our caller from the two one four area
code. Who's calling today from two one four?
Hello, David. This is Dave from Dallas. Hey,
Dave. Yeah. Ken, what's going on? Now, we're
not on speaker, are we?
You know what? You're on my Bluetooth, man.
All right. Not bad.
So what's on your mind? Yeah, it's OK.
OK. Thanks for taking my call. A few weeks
ago, a few weeks ago, you were asked an audience
question about whether the economy does better
under Democrats or Republicans. Right. And
you mentioned so you've mentioned several
metrics, stock market, GDP, unemployment.
But there's another metric you didn't mention,
which is recessions. I was born in 1958 and
there have been 11 recessions in my lifetime.
One of them started when Jimmy Carter was
president. The other 10 was started during
Republican administrations. Jimmy Carter.
Only one Republican in my lifetime. And remember,
I'm 62 years old. Right. Only one Republican
in my lifetime, Gerald Ford, who served less
than two and a half years, didn't have a recession
store while he was president. However, thanks
to his Republican predecessor, Richard Nixon,
we were already in a recession when he took
office under 40. So every Republican in your
lifetime has had a number of recessions equal
to the number of terms they served. Let me
state we can't go four years without causing
a recession. Seriously, how did they maintain
this reputation for being better on the account?
Are they just better at branding?
I think so. I mean, yes, that's so. So it's
all linked to the simplicity of a lot of these
ideas, sort of like, hey, I mean, you know,
taxes are your money and you should keep it.
And it must be better for the economy if people
keep the money they earn. So we're good with
the economy. Right. It's like simple. It's
ideas that are that simple, that take hold.
I just don't know how the American people
can be that easily fooled. It's just crazy.
Well, we we know they can because Trump is
president.
A valid point.
That's why I always wonder, my friend. Thank
you very much. Love your show.
All right. Dave from Dallas. Dave from Dallas
on fire, shot out of a cannon there and getting
right into his point. I love it. Let's go
next to our caller from the nine five four
area code. Who's calling today from nine five
four?
Hello? Yeah. Who's this?
Hi, this is online just in some joy. I'm calling
from Johns Creek, Georgia, Justin.
I love your show. I had to kind of two two
questions, so to speak.
The first the first concerning, let's say,
best case scenario happens in November. We
get when Joe Biden Joe Biden defeats Tom resoundingly.
We stand our John. We Democrats expand our
majority in the House and take back the Senate.
Yeah. What? Are there any potential guardrails
or anything we can do to rumba, like prevent
above, prevent, prevent Trump or under McConnell
and the Republicans from just going going
going off the rails, burning everything down
in the in these six week in the 10 week kind
of 11 weeks between Election Day and when
I head is inaugurated.
Well, assuming you're not literally meaning
starting to burn things down, they can only
really do so much. I mean, Trump would probably
if let's not put the cart before the horse.
But if it gets to that point and Trump has
that two and a half month lame duck period,
I think mostly Trump would risk recede into
a shell and blame everybody other than himself
for losing. If that happens and might not
try to do that much, but the things he would
likely do would include pardoning people,
executive orders that he believes would either
be digs at Obama or Biden or ways to get favors
to his friends.
But I actually don't think that, you know,
the real concern would be do they try to push
more judges through? And that is something
that maybe Democrats would be able to prevent
on the same basis that Mitch McConnell prevented
Merrick Garland from getting to the Supreme
Court. I think if Trump loses, he's going
to be so distraught, he won't be doing very
much during that lame duck period.
I I certainly hope so. I mean, we, um, we
know that he's basically.
My hope is that the worst thing he does is
a sense of nastiness onto petty tweets about
how was rigged or how he was how he was treated
unfairly. But it just was awesome that empty
threats.
Yeah. I mean, the problem about the tweets,
about the problem of tweets, about the election
being rigged, is that as stupid as those would
be, they likely would inspire some of his
followers to potentially become violent. And
that's something that is potentially, potentially
very problematic.
Listen, Justin, I know you had a second question.
I'm going to let you go because your connection
is is not great. And we want to make sure
that we can hear everybody beautifully. So
I have a lot of people holding. I do want
to get to.